foreign
out to Cleveland Ohio and talk to the
Great and Powerful Bradley what's up
Brad
how's it going Dr John I'm doing great
man how are you
uh living the dream sir anytime somebody
says you're living the dream they're for
sure not living the dream
I mean that's the Midwest way I mean
that's what we do
we lie what's up dude
odd
going through life um better question
about relationships uh met this new girl
that's absolutely incredible and she is
in the process of uh going through a
separation and then a divorce
and just feeling some feelings of yeah I
don't want to say shame but you know
uncertainty like I want to know how to
best support her me like who talk about
wanting to be together and I know I you
know truly care about her I know she
feels the same and you know just looking
for some guy inside how to move forward
with that
how honest can I be with you
I'm ready
so you're you're you've fallen for a
married woman
that's like yeah that's the truth yeah
um
the best advice I can give you
just guide a guy sitting across the
table is run as fast as you can
and I know you don't want to hear that
because she's incredible and she's had
some moments where you can reach out and
actually help her because she's been
struggling and
for the rest of your time together you
will wonder when this other shoe drops
and you're the other guy
another stuff I crossed my mind I would
tell you right now man she's cheating on
her herself she's cheating on her even
if she's in the middle of a breakup and
by the way that's the number one thing I
hear from folks who are like no no like
we're already breaking up and there's
their husband or wife has no idea that
they're already breaking up
right
um I would tell you to
as hard as this is going to be I would
tell you to run and maybe and even after
like she gets y'all get divorced or she
gets divorced and there's six months we
all are friends whatever then maybe but
I'm telling you right now dude you're
never gonna be able to sleep
have you already had those feelings
let me ask you this
are you feeling weird that she goes home
to her house with her husband
uh it comes every so often but I mean
generally just can't do my best to you
know not think about that the fact that
she's going home and sleeping in a bed
with another dude
yeah yeah I mean stuff I don't like yeah
she's sleeping with another guy
yeah definitely again no don't like that
um
documents on this Crossing line and I
just again just don't think about it or
do what I do I can't to not think about
it but
I I bet you're being Coy I bet you think
about it a lot
depends on the day I mean we could play
honestly there like some days more on
others other days not
um
yeah I mean I wouldn't say it's on my
mind every waking moment I can't say
with absolute you know honestly that's
never there yeah uh
just I mean again just depends on the
day
how'd this happen man
um
I we uh met through some uh some through
martial arts
um
when I first met her
she uh
there's like instantaneous chemistry and
at no point would I've ever thought she
was married then she didn't have a ring
on like just the way they was looking
like there was nothing that was seemed
you know married woman
um
and at that point I knew like if she if
I met her again it would have been a you
know an issue for me because I felt the
chemistry right away and that when I was
in a relationship so I didn't do
anything you know
ah
then a couple months later about we met
up again at that point I wasn't and I
was like oh you know it definitely just
kind of spurred from there but
I think uh just I think it's just so
much of the compatibility like that
instantaneous chemistry but
it doesn't really work as well if you
know the story be so much different if
she wasn't already married
yeah I mean the story would always be
different if dot dot dot fill in the
blank if they were taller faster funnier
made more money no absolutely weren't
married right
um
I mean I can't lie I figured it was the
uh I fear of the um what you said there
about running be the you know I figure
that's what you're gonna say why haven't
you yet not what I wanted to hear I know
why haven't you what okay because think
about this you met her she was married
yeah and yeah even your own words like I
wouldn't even have known
which told me she was flirty she was fun
she was hilarious she was a good martial
arts competitor like
a corner not uh the Cornerstone of her
life
yeah
you didn't even know about it um so put
yourself on the other side of that man
what happens when when that happens to
you
now I
you bring up a lot of stuff that I've
thought about and I promise I have and
naively or ignorantly I push it away
um I ever saw a lot easier say oh that
wouldn't be me
um
I think at this point not not running
I've been again so easy to call up in
the feelings and the emotion and
right wrong or indifferent we have been
through nothing romantic but we've been
through different things like there's
she's had various medical stuff that
I've been the only person that's been
there with her because
she didn't trust her husband or family
to be there
um I'm gonna tell you right hey Brad I'm
gonna tell you right now I'm gonna tell
you I'm gonna tell you right now dude
she's playing you yeah
here's what's happening she found
herself in really really deep water
and you happen to swim by so she clung
to you
and she'll cling to you until the Smoke
Clears on this thing
good old school trauma Bond amen it's
not even trauma bunny dude like there's
not a bond here this is a this is
someone holding on to you for dear life
and you like the warmth of that hug and
I don't blame you I don't blame you at
all
um
but you have to see that what you're
feeling and experiencing is not real
it feels so intense and so good and so
right and there's none of it is real
if you were to call me and say hey six
months uh like I just met this woman
she's amazing she just got uh divorced
six months ago and I'm thinking about
asking her out or whatever I would tell
you to be careful then
right but you don't you don't even feel
comfortable being Brad right now you
don't feel comfortable being
in a relationship with a married woman
right
no I don't so what what is it about this
whole thing that is making you
take what you feel and just throw it
away or just put it in a paper shredder
and just keep plowing forward
again I guess it could just be naivety
it could be ignorance could just be
getting so caught up in the emotion
that's there with it
um genuinely trusting and believing that
you know what she's saying and how she's
acting is that
she wants that new relationship that new
life and she wants it with me but
ignoring the potential downfalls in the
you know the whole that I'm digging with
it
I would even go as far to say as I don't
know that she's I wouldn't call her a
liar right out of the gate I don't think
she's lying to you
no I mean I don't think she is I don't
I think she doesn't know either
let me just give you the stats on it
yeah I uh 100 of the time I've never
seen this work
now I'm gonna get all kind of there's
gonna be a bajillion people in the
YouTube comments they're like no one
time fine
I don't know those people yeah I don't
know
I I don't know him
sometimes people will meet some I do
know of people who are like have full-on
affairs and go on get divorced and be
with the person they're having an affair
with and that goes on fine
um
I can hear in you you really have
feelings for this person
and you understand that you have
feelings for somebody and a house that's
on fire
no that's that's right
so what's your question like how can I
help you I know I've kind of just taken
all the air out of everything
no I mean
I mean the genuine question was you know
how could I best support her or myself
and you know at that point it was like a
future us but the due to us has been
deflated you know
yeah probably rightfully so I mean you
know a lot easier just blaze the trail
ahead without looking around to see
what's going on
um
if this is going to be a hard thing to
hear but it has not been your job to
take care of her
that's been her husband's job and her
family's job if she's in an abusive
situation she's getting beat up whatever
um
that's a whole other situation and it
doesn't sound like what's going on here
and
that separation is not a lengthy drawn
out process
so I would ask you if if she was so
committed to this why is she still going
back to that same house
I mean for her words it was um
finding housing which she just did
and then um with the medical staff the
insurance was with him so she was
holding on to it for that
explanations maybe excuses no but
I'm a psychological standpoint I it made
sense to me emotionally it's you know
just kind of hit me up inside but yeah
and it's still eating you up inside
nowadays
and if you think about it from her side
she got a free pass she didn't have to
deal with the relationship challenges
that she she may or may not have
um she just got this guy that swooped in
and gave her rise took care of money
took care of meals took care of
emotional needs
um she didn't have to do the hard work
of asking for help dealing with her
marriage From the Inside Out dealing
with her family situation didn't have to
deal with any of that stuff she just had
this white knight that showed up and
ta-da
and the moment that there's not a say a
need to be saved
there will be a reckoning of some sort
um that is definitely something I've
thought about I mean
ah how old are you briefly 26 okay
briefly what were you gonna say
I said I've definitely something I
thought about you know however briefly I
wouldn't say just ignored it entirely
but after thinking about being
beyond that just uh temporary thing that
is just you know cling to the person
that happens to be there
um you know it's a tough time so of
course she's looking for a life raft and
then after that just can be you know
said and done over with
um it's definitely something I thought
about and for sure something I've pushed
away even more because I'm like no I
can't be the reality but it's the
reality
the person that you have feelings for
right now woke up in the bed of another
man this morning
that's the reality
that's reality and
at 26 this is probably the hardest thing
you've ever done Maybe not maybe you've
been through a bunch of crap in your
life and whatever but
um
I think that the right the right call
here is
I'm gonna call her on the phone and say
hey I can't I can't talk to you anymore
When the Smoke Clears from everything
and a divorce is finalized and all that
then possibly
um maybe
but I you can't you Brad let me talk
just to you you cannot enter into a
romantic relationship and just start
pretending reality isn't real facts
aren't actually facts right you can't
just pretend like I'm just not gonna
pretend that she goes home to this other
guy every night I'm not going to pretend
that we've been
um having deep conversations we may have
hooked up a few times
but she's been saying it just takes a
while just takes a process it just takes
time I'm slowly working on it I'm gonna
do this and we're gonna be together
forever you you can't enter into a
relationship just shoving all that stuff
down it's real it's real and let's be
super awesome it's killing you and it
should be killing you
there are people who can just be like I
don't care
I've seen her and her husband but what
we have is between us
and
knock your lights out but that's not you
ma'am that's not you
but you're gonna probably what would
happen is if you did this it would be
like I thought and you said and so
you're just gonna leave me here to do
all this by myself yep I am
and if she turns the tables on you and
starts accusing you of stuff and starts
but you said that now you really have
all your answers
because I would say somebody who's
dealing with a relationship falling
apart with Integrity would say hey
um I like you I like spending time with
you
it's not fair to you to drag you through
what I'm going through right now and I
love having you around but it's not
smart it's not safe it's not it's not
it's not reality
when I all the Smoke Clears from this
then I'll reach out
but until then man please follow your
gut on this one
and your gut is so true and your gut is
saying run brother run
so I'll just tell you I'll speak up on
behalf of your guts run
walk away
and do it with dignity
um
but you gotta you gotta back out of this
one man
you gotta back out of this one
and man you know that you know
sorry man I wish I could have given you
some some happier news to start this
show but
um
she's cheating on herself she's cheating
on her husband she's cheating on her
family she's cheating on you
and that's not a great way for you
that's not a good
um
ecosystem for you to start some new
relationship right now